you know joe biden is doing miserably it
is they they are they need a hail mary
desperate pass to try and pull this off
and so i we end up getting this ad where
an absolutely
desperate democrat candidate they know
they're losing
now i don't know what's going to happen
for all we know democrats end up winning
sure fine whatever the red wave is
what's being predicted because
republicans are up in the generic ballot
this guy
made a campaign ad with a noose around
his own neck huh and progressives are
calling it
bold what courageous and i'm like well
that is true you got to have balls of
steel to make a campaign but when i saw
this i was just like it was kind of a
moment of realization for me
for the first it's the craziest
political ad i've ever seen in my
lifetime unless i'm forgetting something
like which is possible there was another
one where they were like running people
down in maga trucks or something
that was also crazy but you know before
like growing up the campaign ads were
like my opponent wants to raise taxes
and he voted no on the safer schools act
now it's a guy he puts a news around his
neck and he's like look what they've
done to me
wow he put this noose around my neck and
said this is mega country
rand paul poured bleach on me outside of
subway that's right the media is like
rand what do you have to say for
yourself and he's like i didn't do it
and they're like he's lying he admits it
i i never did that like well that's what
you would say if you did it you did it i
do agree i've never seen an ad where
they make themselves the victim when
someone's running for office and is like
look how badly i've been treated vote
vote for me that's also a very good
point that's such a bizarre strategy to
be like i
am a victim it's like
we were supposed to like leaders what is
this i got i do have to point out yes i
did not remember this one virginia ad
features minority kids chased by truck
with gillespie sticker and confederate
flag
yeah this is just the scare tactics
it's it's like they're writing fanfics
they are they are see but see the
difference is this is a normal ad the
news
no yeah we'll play it
like what is this what is this white
dude the confederate flag doing they
made sure he turned his head slowly
though he's running down minority kids
what does it look like
but i don't think he actually does
anything to the kids he doesn't well
whoever whatever politician this was
probably intervened before he got a
chance to do so all right i bet he did i
actually know
i actually think this is a really good
commercial
run
yeah like what what is it what does the
guy even do oh no not the guests and
flag
he's gonna run him over oh is this a
nightmare how did it become night so
fast
this is actually i think this is a good
commercial i know the psa is like maybe
stop fabricating fake hate crimes and
scaring the crap out of your children
exactly good idea these kids are having
nightmares because you scream in their
faces about things they don't got to be
worrying about for the most part the kim
klasik ads were really good that she had
those were good yeah that was a good
example of high production value uh but
focusing on whatever issues she wanted
to talk about in the community you know
walking the streets of baltimore i just
want to point out they took the tweet
they took that unbelievably banal
histrionic dramatic left-wing tweet that
we see every couple months and made a
commercial the my kids said to me i'm
scared because republican is going to do
x it's like your kid didn't say that
you're making this up what's wrong with
you they took they took that and they
made it a commercial do you remember the
the lincoln is it the lincoln project
their commercial that they had where it
was like four more years and i didn't
know you could serve three terms
you remember that commercial yeah
oh my god no it was uh it was um
it was donald trump in a pickup truck
chasing down abe lincoln probably yeah
jeez he hates america see but the thing
about these commercials is they're
i don't i don't want to give them any
sort of gravitas but at least they're
legit the thing with the noose is just a
publicity stunt yeah this guy's running
in kentucky against rand paul he knows
he's not going to win he's trying to get
twitter followers to parlay that into a
job at msnbc
that's his goal that's what a lot of it
always feels like to me is that they're
looking they know they're not going to
win especially in like specific
districts yeah he's trying to get
attention so that he can make his next
career move well he clearly literally
wants victim points by actually putting
a noose around his neck like i can't
think of a more direct parallel to being
like oh look at me i'm a victim give me
a job at msnbc
oh man we gotta wait we gotta let me let
me make sure good night america
america one of the funnier goodness
gracious
oh yeah blow this one up
don't let the bed bugs bite
look at that color scheme it's so dark
this is that meme where the kids like
mommy donald trump is a fascist
it's like a red white like an american
flag blanket
you asked me to wake you and tell you
what happened in the election
oh no he did not yes he did yes he did
the kid definitely did that no school
tomorrow
look at her
be
face
this is so cringe
not anymore
hold on wait a minute she was
oh my gosh
what just one second all right just
besides everything that is obviously
wrong with this
if he was running for president after he
had already served two terms
why would the kid be confused about the
possibility of him winning
the idea that you can only have two
terms is not voter enforced it's not
like we let them run again and then the
american people don't know he had two
terms we're not voting but only after he
wins exactly oh no but it's literally
election night
she says donald trump might win and he
goes wake me up when we find out and
then she wakes up and goes but i thought
you could only serve two terms like why
did you ask then why did you ask
making me get up in the middle of the
night to tell you about something you
didn't even know about
uh son we've been over this in some
insane fascistic way that the lincoln
project dreamed up he changed the law
that's why he was running again that's
why there was the election i gotta i
gotta give a shout out because this ad
was actually like it may as well have
been a trump ad like an ad for trump
yeah dude and so yeah
like after all the trump supporters were
like yeah
like this is hilarious it's got more
play i think than any it got more so
remember the uh yeah whatever it is
remember the carpe dongdam meme
where it was like
oh my gosh it was amazing it's like
trump 2020 2024 2028 2032 and then it
just goes to infinity and that they
wrote articles where they were like
trump supporters want trump to be
president for life so they're they're
like they're like
trump would be president for more than
two terms and you know who i love fdr
best president we ever had we need
someone like him
they worship the man he served four
terms as president by the way fdr before
the 22nd amendment was passed but he
died shortly into his future dudes
served so many terms they had to pass an
amendment
no more if you do so much of something
that someone has to pass a
constitutional amendment you are a
problem
they say that fdr was the most fascist
president he and woodrow wilson i don't
want to derail
no yeah that they were there they were
bad
two terms you think that's good
president should be able to serve
one term one six year term one six year
term yeah think about it i mean i'm not
entirely fully settled on this i just
think you know in terms of the president
having to run for reelection
when you get into the last two years of
their four-year term it turns into silly
season right and people start cutting
checks for
okay who do what vote do i need okay i
need minorities in wisconsin wisconsin
what do they need and then you federal
money goes to them like that like you
get rid of that with one six-year
presidential term now that that is
assuming that i believe the president
should have as much power as he does
which i do not or she does
uh so you know that's really insightful
it's very muddling to have a president
running for office and trying to be the
president yeah
well and it i feel like i don't know
that doesn't seem crazy one six-year
term like it seems like a yeah but
it's a good compromise i think for one
four-year term is just not enough well
one four-year term is your your
i don't know i can be swayed
yeah things happen fast now they happen
a lot faster than they used to
information travels a lot faster
well then they push stuff off to se like
they start pushing stuff off on their on
like what they plan to get done right so
they're like oh well we'll focus on that
for the second term so they start
pushing stuff on the agenda off until
term two you know under the context that
they're actually going to win so if you
give them one six year term that forces
them to do all that they want to work on
right then and then but then how do you
talk about like congress in the senate
like would that be along the same lines
as like uh
uh
you know
don't keep into the weeds there
so this this this ad the good night
america thing was put up on october 22nd
2020 i just think it's funny that
they
they make this ad
and in 2019 we had the best numbers of
our lives in the economy
and so the worst thing they could think
of was that trump would just win again
because they had no real argument
against him
i i i honestly you'd ask people like
okay what don't you like about trump and
they'd be like he's a fascist or
whatever they wouldn't give you a real
reason that's why that i think they made
the sad because they were like people
don't know why they hate trump they just
want him to go away
and they don't want him to go away
because people are screaming in their
ears in the media
so they voted for a guy who tanked the
economy
his son
is driving gas prices through the roof
apparently is is conversing on um the
finer links to porn with his child
just i mean the apple doesn't fall far
from the tree and so now here we are
the average person i mean man
spending like what you're gonna spend
like 70 to 100 bucks to fill up your gas
tank
but hey three three terms of trump oh
that would have been the worst right
there was uh like literally the other
day i was scrolling instagram and i had
three stories in a row where it was like
friends posting their gas like filling
up their gas tank where it's like going
over 80 and says thanks joe biden and
like all three of them were like like
one had like a sticker on it one said
thanks joe biden and the other one just
was like a middle finger and it's just
all people focusing on the fact that
they can't afford to drive anymore i
swear i think it's the federal reserve
has been planning to crash this for a
while and they're blaming trump and
biden and they're making us blame trump
and biden and this has just been a
fascist move since they know it was
falling apart who's blaming trump
well some people some people that just
hate him and yeah but it's the these
guys are not the ones that caused this
this is like banking cartels let's talk
about i think the the uh
the q and on people who think he had a
third term are blaming him they're like
why is he letting this happen yeah that
was that was actually one of the things
i will give um
that uh was that guy's name jordan
klepper is that his name
he he's he talks to a q a guy and he's
like so you think trump is really the
president he's like yes he is he's like
why is he making gas prices so high and
the guy's like no that's joe biden he's
like but you said that trump was
president i'm like yeah okay those
people thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast if
you want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at
8pm and don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time